well our trip was over and I'm happy to
say that not even Jordan could ruin
Italy for me
we had an unforgettable time and our
journeys already being lauded as a
triumph of classic Italian cinema ladies
and gentlemen here is the movie trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
the owner a sister Ketchel dato england
st no Arriva the world before una
inertia Toledo minute is stupid attack
festival de Cannes Vinci tour let there
are a few to give an option do before
knee
vonabell latina macchiato xi hu
Edinburgh International Film Festival
Mirage adoro scafati - Aventura the
sulla request apologies
spare a mentor a la mort Eliza
[Music]
Donna not a doll vaticano a de yada yada
somos el Pasto by Bella Terra mr. Vega
meant a Travis oral antibiotic in the
chili Louis Prakriti or Olas prolific
con Connell O'Brien Jordans glands when
she told her failed partnership at Sione
assembly
[Applause]
[Music]
tchau tchau words every went from in the
class she's asking if I'm your assistant
no he does not see some yen 50 yo body
corn he does not have the vocabulary of
the Italian language but he has the
drama will you how do you see hands mine
she has the authority in this room she
is the teacher she is in control they
are well-behaved they listen and look at
you you're an animal leader brochure she
said I'm an animal did you say on an
animal I am paraphrasing okay I should
probably explain to students left they
couldn't take it anymore ray can you say
why you think those two left okay
[Music]
you
you